[Applause]
this is why i say you're the greatest
troll and i mean this sincerely
i'm not sure i just i mean no no no
that's just me though trolling
yo connor is a fantastic troll yeah but
like okay okay
i still like [ __ ] with you like i [ __ ]
with my best friends you know how about
this how about this
remove the word troll because there's
like negative connotation on youtube i
don't mind being controlled by like yo
like that's just who i am like gaining
interest there's gravity you know how to
create some gravity right so
with this ben askren jake paul fight
yeah
you were the first choice of course yeah
yeah so you are built into this hype as
well
yeah but jake is such a [ __ ] bro so
because i was like yo because
no let me honest so they offered me the
date i said yo is it um be honest
i feel bad for his bro his brother's in
the room right now his brother's like
my voice is so bad yeah i've been
[ __ ] uh yeah
no but yeah he was there when that [ __ ]
happened bro okay break it down break it
down so my voice is [ __ ] up right it's
okay it's all good but jake
is a [ __ ] bro he offered me something
like gordon bro no i know don't
mention him at least like a little bit
you know gordon's come on he has like a
lisp and everything i feel bad for the
kids
i'm doing charity work at this point
come on stop it
he's nice as well you have to give him
some questions stop it
if he's not attractive then that's
indicative of you not being good
because i was in my training i went to a
[ __ ] rough decision
he's at the door licking the [ __ ]
floor and trying to get in bro at the
door
he's like this yeah he's like dylan get
me in come on please oh my god
wait no listen you gotta stick on one
topic because you guys are [ __ ] me up
all right go
go go gonna have something yes i'm
having it but we're getting yeah yeah
yeah paw patrol come on okay let's do it
right somebody's not the best
you've ever had it's not but
no not jameson but if we're gonna have
like nice whiskey i like that that's the
best you've ever had taste in some come
on
trolling for the show no no no no i'm
not it's not i'm trolling bro it's not i
believed everything you said
until right now i don't even know if you
were kikis last night
i wasn't been there bro i've been where
were we gonna start at okay
so jake hits you up about the fight okay
so yeah so i was like yo my knees [ __ ]
so the funny part is i'm gonna fight him
with his knee like this i'm like
okay let's fight this and that back up
one second you had
pretty serious knee surgery very serious
twelve hours right yeah
three ligaments so you mcl
i'm not gonna say the you know what i
mean like i never said it before oh
really yeah i never i just i got knee
surgery because i don't know
yeah you think you could give someone an
advantage yeah i'm not advantaged but
like actually like you know what to say
about
fair enough so i told him m-c-l-a-c-l
i said i'll take it up the whole thing's
gone
no i don't have a knee anymore okay so
the doctor was like
yo you can't do this it's not my just
let me do it like this [ __ ]
sucks bro
he's terrible no you can't do it cause
if so basically it wasn't about
him it was more like if i stepped the
wrong way i could have to like get
another surgery
so they're like yo like is it worth
redoing your knee for jay paul
i'm like no i mean like who cares about
him really in reality you know what i
mean
so i'm like no just let me do it it's
not that big of a deal they're like yo
if you step one wrong way
you have to get another surgery and be
out for another year yeah just wait wait
so i text we were dming at the time when
i was you just give me an extra month i
said give me one more month off
the date that he wanted oh so you
wouldn't want to push it back i just
said one month and he wouldn't do it he
just wanted me injured you know so i was
like
oh so you think you got the offer
because
i was injured of an injury and now she's
coming off a freaking hip surgery
yeah you could barely walk he's like 50
years old oh you think so he you think
jake is taking advantage
one month before one month i say yo give
me one extra month and that's it
and he was like oh we have a date so i
say bro i thought you were the show
you're thrilled this isn't that
one month you can't do it no he didn't
do it
juan bro i mean so you think that you
would beat him up in a boxing match
i'm just saying he's nice i heard i
heard that he can box
i heard he can box and i know guys that
you work out with
we both work out in the same gym in new
york exactly right so i know you've been
okay okay okay
okay i'm gonna explain to you right now
i guess you know i don't want to give my
game plan away because i'm gonna fight
him if he
if he beats ben or whoever the winner is
i'm fighting oh really yeah so okay so
not that you're soft you're from new
york you have more near toughness than
him
okay right i don't know if i'm tougher
than him yeah but you got hands right i
don't know if i have hands
i'm a sweetheart okay so yo say i walked
you down for [ __ ] you you boxed
before
say what yeah say i watch you down for
12 minutes yeah yeah i'll tell your arms
and be
yeah you're gonna be okay that's what i
heard okay but yeah think about ben
oscar
that's a four three time ncaa champion
olympian that has something like this
jake don't have that bro he's [ __ ]
spoon fed bro yeah come on oh you think
that aspen's got heart and ashlyn's
gonna walk him down and exhaust him i'm
gonna tell you the fight right now and
i'm gonna
mark my words watch what's gonna happen
first jake's gonna uh cheers
i got the [ __ ] plastic call but you
know it's all good this is what it is
jason to throw mad punches in the first
round he might rock him a little bit
yeah
ben ashton's chin is nice you think
cause he got hit with that knee he has a
bad chin not a lot of
that [ __ ] knee could have [ __ ]
destroyed a car yeah
yeah yeah he got big shots from um
robert laura robbie landed huge bombs i
think robert laurie
no that's a good point and especially
with four ounce gloves that's what i'm
saying i i
understand i've heard that perspective
and i spoke to ben about it and that's
what ben said
his plan was as well he's like he's
gonna land yeah i think that i'll put
enough pressure on him and i'll put him
in a position
where it will be incredibly
uncomfortable for him and he hasn't had
that many fights where he gets
comfortable in the danger zone
yeah so here's my question with you so
you're thinking
because i've asked people in the gym
about you and this is what they said
they're like
you hit incredibly hard yeah and you hit
incredibly hard especially
someone would say say what mike tyson jr
or someone said no one said that
last minute
but i was there scared i was dead wait
i thought you're from like queens or
something that's why you didn't show up
you know whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
karate champion right here thank you
in here